[Music]
there comes a time in every man's life
for a woman's life it doesn't matter
which when you got to go to the beach
you've got to feel the power the ocean
the raw unbridled rage of the waves
smashing up against the sand and sand it
is the breath of life for those people
that live on the beach of which we are
and in that sand we build our greatest
monuments that we have ever known
castles castles which stand the
testament of time we'll be there for all
ages to come and in that epic history of
sandcastle making there stands a legend
above all else all others will shy away
from the shy that he is tyler the castle
side oh no man stands as tall no man
stands as resolute made from sand
himself from the very Beach is of
Lithuania if you could even imagine what
kind of man he is
oh you're wrong he's totally different
or something but then by comparison oh
it is Ethan
quicksand myths sir a man who stands
resolute but illusory
I think that's a word yes unable to be
tangible when you got the sand of his
soul inside of him breathed it in
indescribable unknowable and just like
quicksand we draw you in with his eyes
oh yes and you may be asking Who I am
among these tities of sand castle oh I
think you already know it's me mark
sandy would let me let me describe it
it's so packed full of sand
Oh a pearl yes that's for you
magic I know and yet here on this Beach
we are head to head to head against each
other to try to build the best
sandcastle possible can we do it panel
thank you alright so here's the rules
we're all gonna build a sandcastle we
got we got buckets with which to do it
we got [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I am so sorry hang on we're
gonna we're gonna go with these shovels
have power with which you don't
understand no one can know the power of
the sand I'm sorry why I've gotta stab
you vagina okay alright so we're gonna
take these I'm gonna build the best
sandcastle we can in five minutes based
on history that's subject to change see
we'll see about that we've got these
artifacts here with which to build our
castles these priceless antiques have
been passed down through the generations
to us misguided as they be view maybe
I'm gonna die that's enough of that
we're gonna get going anybody got the
timer alright ready three two one go
[Music]
it is what they are they don't know
nothing about sand
quicksand Nestor obviously already so
full of moisture because it took me to
get anymore
as you all may know the key to a good
sand castle is the parapets oh [ __ ] did
you guys know that my family couldn't
afford to go to the beach so I never
actually built the sand castle in my
life really this is the first time I've
ever built a sand castle really yeah
ignore all the lies that I said during
the intro I've literally never never
built the sand castle in my life oh it's
beautiful
just something close to my heart your
vagina
[Laughter]
yeah a sombrero oh oh oh ah yes perfect
it's just like a boob exactly what I was
going for oh never mind looks more like
a boob break cool boy
wait I got it I don't think it's like a
fire oh I'm just trying to sweet-talk
one of the judges now decorating with
birds that's all I can hope for at the
moment they're gonna work you guys have
to be impartial judges that was not also
not in the rules field you're funny
oh do we have a time check oh boy Oh
disaster look two one that's the
countdown I didn't hear Oh
talk louder ah Oh
interesting choice I saw I see ah good
yes all right
so let's explain it all right Ethan
youyou first me first yeah go for it
so I was going for more of a village
field at the top you have the the king's
palace surrounded by his knights and
there's a nice gate around it it's very
it's a very special place up front here
obviously we have a moat with alligators
actually inside this other thing can be
protected at all times
another gate right up front we've got
the two towers up here that symbolize
both darkness and lightness in the world
and each tower holds the magic of the
dark and the light and is held here in
the villa
Tyler explain yours certainly mine is
the traditional pillars of power castle
clearly with the distinct moat
functional drawbridge I'd like to point
out that the seahorse and not a draw a
drawbridge
okay and of course the towers and walls
for defense along with a full completed
surrounding moat the villager town with
a platform on top for when obviously the
King decides he wants to kill somebody
and the the ultimate altar which on top
sits the King throne watching over his
entire village okay all right
rank amateur work guys I do admit but I
think I've got you beat and here's why
as you may notice I have a tendency to
reenact historical events and this one
is no different because as you see there
is a built in channel 4 with which me to
sit down and if you notice oh is that
Mickey Mouse on the front yes this is a
complete recreation of the Disney movie
Aladdin and the Genie scene where he
lifted the palace up because true to
life size I sit here as the genie and
this is the pathless of Agrabah and in
doing so I haven't swept I need I say
well I think that we have to leave that
up to the impartial judges oh it's very
clear my intention the Disney logo
reinforces it you see that and this is
very clearly the palace from Agrabah
very these are the friendly these are
the tube the tube things that almost
squished Aladdin in the winter excuse my
snug did you see you see that you see
you see that you you see that you see
pretty good you see that though the one
thing I will say that's not a
three creationists you have a
significant number of ducks and I don't
remember ducks in them they never showed
you the outside of Agrabah but it's true
according to historical records there
were a great number of ducks in that
place Bill O'Reilly odd for a desert but
it was true I'm trying to remember the
lyrics from the song just wanted gooses
alright now I will say I will say yours
is probably the most defendable castle
ain't nobody getting in through that
drawbridge because that drawbridge is a
seahorse don't even it's even better
because then if they try to walk on it
it'll attack them exactly the time it'll
wrap its tail about a single yeah and I
gotta say that also I like yours because
it seems homey it's very nice I'm now
noticing that it makes a face there's
two eyes nose and mouth didn't even
realize that I will say this too it
seems that Ethan made the largest and
most structures he did yeah so now we
leave it up to the impartial judges who
are not law that's okay Aladin oh the
one that word each okay Aladdin genie
Agrabah strong drawbridge defense happy
little accident
[Laughter]
extremely sandy vagina
[Applause]
that's what we agreed on
yay
thank you
[Laughter]
that's what we agreed on we wouldn't
kill everybody if Tyler won but
literally that is what we do
[Music]
all right so this has been the
sandcastle-building thing I guess the
official name is this has been
markiplier billed to Santa
this man markiplier makes a sand castle
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed this one hope you
learned something about sandcastle
history yourself and you know as we say
here at markiplier Inc ready don't keep
saying in your image in denying us
that's a bad one bye bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
dickie something touch my foot it's not
there now touchdown I don't know monster
shark prolly yeah